during the 75th annual Hunger Games the
arena is set up like a clock Tick Tock
which of these threats happens at 3:00
these are amazingly difficult good for
you I have no clue
remember psycho at what time the
lightning struck it's daytime for the
jabber Jays and daytime for the blood
rain so it has to be one of those two
we're working together so smart I wasn't
even I think it's the Jabra Jays
assuming that the game started like noon
but I don't remember makes you just
assume they started you assume they
start at noon I don't know it's a clock
and a clock goes like this the beginning
12 seems like a reasonable time can
sleep in put on their suits get have
time to give coffee a little light
brunch yeah yeah it's important you got
to be fed to fight to the death I'm
going for it sorry no it's not oh no we
all got it wrong again